- What am I doing right now?
Like where am I going?
What am I doing?
- [Tyler] You're on this
for Daymond John's book.
- And what am I doing?
- [Tyler] You're
talking with him.
- He's fireside chatting me.
- [Tyler] Yep.
- Great.
- [Tyler] Good.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
By the way, everything I do is
always intended to figure out
who's a winner
and who's a loser.
That's what it's about.
It's binary.
How you react to something is a
telltale sign of
your feelings internally.
It's how you scale.
That's how you really scale EQ.
That's how you scale.
You do things
that expose people.
How people react to
things is who they are.
What's cookin'?
- I just wanted to
talk to you, that's all.
- I'm glad.
And like, make you win for what
I can control and you've got
your part to control
because of the way I've managed.
I know a lot more about you.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- [Gary] I need those
white spaces for you to be you.
Strengths,
weaknesses, curiosities,
growth, historical context.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- [Gary] So when we do things
it's also an insight on people.
You have people that
are literally A+ players,
crushing it, every feedback
they've gotten is phenomenal.
We have a restructure and
they're crying and texting
are they gonna lose their job.
- [Sara] Right.
- That's important
for me to know that
oh, my God, that
person's massive insecure.
- [Sara] Right, right.
- So I can help them.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
- But if I circumvent
it up front with,
"Sally, you're fine."
- [Sara] Yeah.
- I would never know.
- [Sara] Yeah, yeah.
- Communism, capitalism.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Sara] Yes.
- Macro management, not micro.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- I'm doing it
'cause I want to help.
- [Sara] Yeah. Okay.
- Cool, right?
- [Sara] That one I got.
- Good.
- That makes sense, right?
- Yeah.
- You know how
much that helps me?
- [Sara] Probably fuck ton.
- Now we can help that person
'cause we want them to be here.
- [Sara] Right. Cool.
- Cool.
- [Sara] Thank you.
- I love spending time with you.
(Sara laughs)
- [Sara] I was like,
"Oh, it's 2017 let's
just have a little QT."
- Alright,
let's do it. Let's go.
("You're Welcome Sir" By JMKM)
- I like my (inaudible).
Very good.
What's up, Sammy?
Hey, how are ya?
Good.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are
you, man? Welcome.
- Hi, I'm Davielle Waldner.
- [Gary] Hi, give me a
hug. Sam just gets a dap.
Actually you know what, Sam?
- Bring it in.
- [Gary] Yeah, man.
Bring it in.
How you guys doing?
Welcome, I'll see you soon.
Is this your whole like now that
I'm doing this thing I'm just
not gonna cut any
hair off anywhere.
You're a man.
No, you're a man.
You're just a man.
- That's it.
- More, more, more.
Hello.
- [Josh] Hey bud.
- Hey bud.
- [Josh] If you're gonna impart
some wisdom on a salesperson to
try and get them to get a
straight answer from some type
of prospect, what
would you say to them?
Because it is so hard.
You're not the other person but
what do you need to do for them
to come back and say--
- I'm a little bit
different on this one.
- [Josh] I don't
know if you're different.
- My answer,
well, let's find out.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- My answer is don't chase them
and move on to the next one.
I do not sell the unsellable.
If you don't return my email
and if you're dodging me and if
you're coming up with excuses
three minutes before the call,
I have no interest
in chasing you.
- [Josh] How
long do you give it?
- Not a whole lot.
I'm a salesman so my intuition--
- [Josh] Try to
go back 10 years.
- I'm going back to being a
13-year-old selling
baseball cards, I'm
telling you the truth.
This is why I told you I was
going to be different but I also
think that I'm as
good of a salesman as
the most
attractive girl on Earth.
What I mean by that is the
most attractive girl on Earth's
advice to picking up guys is
gonna look different then the,
than the average pillar, right?
- [Josh] Sure.
- She's not working it.
It's coming to her.
- [Josh] Right.
- I think I've always
sold stuff I believe in,
I've always been
great at selling and so,
for me, I just have no
interest in chasing you.
And so, what I'm
getting at is the following.
First of all, salespeople and
boy is this the best piece of
advice I can give, the amount
of people that are in sales that
sell shit that they don't
believe in is extraordinary.
Let me say it 15 more times.
The amount of sales people that
sell stuff they don't believe in
is extraordinary which
means you've already lost.
I will say the one thing that
non-winning salespeople do,
the 85% of the market who are
successful but eventually won't
be or will play themselves out
or tap out is they say no for
the other guy and girl.
Oh, they're not gonna.
- [Josh] Yeah, yeah.
- If you're a
salesman that says no,--
- [Josh] Yep.
- You've lost.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- [Gary] I love you, man.
- [Josh] I love you.
- [Tiffany] Good to see you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Tiffany] I'm good,
I'm really good.
- [Gary] Good. Awesome.
- [Tiffany] It's like when you
put a challenge in front of me
that I'm passionate
about, that's the thing.
My only concern with sports is
that it's been I never want to
get pigeonholed
because being--
- I get it.
- [Tiffany] female in sports
but now I'm pigeonholed a
different way because being a
female in tech it's like oh.
You're a female
in tech, sign her up.
- Darlin',
you're a minority woman.
You're gonna be
pigeonholed your whole life.
- [Tiffany] Pretty much.
- Like, people get pigeonholed.
- [Tiffany] You
don't get pigeonholed.
You break out the box
and make up your own shit.
- But I get pigeonholed, right?
The first articles
about VaynerMedia was
wine boy wants to start agency.
- [Tiffany] Fair.
- People get pigeonholed.
- [Tiffany] True.
- Like, you know the best
way not to be pigeonholed?
Execute.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- Punch them in fucking mouth.
- [Tiffany] (laughs)
Yeah, that works for me.
- Right?
Like we're all pigeonholed
whether no matter what where you
come from or
what, everybody's been.
Do you know the level of
disrespect I have for white rich
kid on the Upper East Side.
I don't think he,
white rich boy.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- I don't think he has fire.
- I pigeonhole him that
he's been given everything
and he can't be in--
- [Tiffany] And he's never
had to struggle for anything,
so true.
- So everybody's pigeonholed
so instead of like everybody
debating everybody
being pigeonholed and
their one struggle,--
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- the whole game
is what you've done.
You've executed.
I need this history lesson.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- I think we all
have too much ego,
like when people say to me, "Oh
sorry I didn't know who you
"were," like if I'm in a good
setting like South-By where,--
- Yeah.
- I'm always like, "I know.
"Like 99% of people
don't know who I am."
Do you know what I mean?
So I think the other thing with
pigeonholing is like I tell my
people all the time, your
ego's getting the best of you.
Nobody really gives a fuck.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, true.
Very true.
- Right?
- [Tiffany] (laughs) Yes.
So like I'm not
worried about that.
To me, it's the reverse.
To me, it's like shit
that's the game you love.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- So is there
something to be done there.
Okay, send me that email.
- [Tiffany] Yes, absolutely.
- Alright, good to
see you. Yeah, of course.
I was intrigued to do it.
- [Tiffany] I love that you're
so efficient with time though.
- It matters.
- [Tiffany] I was gonna say,
time is more value to me than
money because money you
can always make more of,
time I can't.
- The other thing, the other
thing you're feeling here is
I want to get a deal done.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- Let's just get right to it.
- [Tiffany] True.
- And if we can't, great.
We got a long journey.
We can do it in 16 years.
But I think a lot of people
just take meetings pander.
Like they take up time
'cause they're not trying
to get anything done.
- [Tiffany] I get it.
- I'm trying to get things done.
("The Plan" by Rey Topol)
Look at that good looking man.
Not only is he very good looking
but he's one of the great
athletes of all time.
- What's up, brother?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- Where were you Live?
- [Gary] No, this will
be on DailyVee, not live.
- [Brandon] Okay.
- [Gary] How you doing?
- [Brandon] Good, man.
- It's good to see you.
How was Super Bowl for you?
- It was cool.
- Good. You did a bunch of,
everybody's saying
you were really hustling.
I'm like, of
course, he's hustling.
- Yeah.
- Like superstar off the field.
So you guys talking about the
website right now, still?
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- [Nate] Right now and then Alex
is coming and we're gonna talk
about people...
- You will have thousands more
people going to your gyms if you
just listen to me.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
See that's the deal is like is
you get the wrong strategy it
just doesn't work, you know?
Get a 1,000 new followers here.
300, it's just too
much work to be honest.
- I get it.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- So let me tell you
what to do that will
bring you the most value.
- [Brandon] Okay.
- It'll cost you three--
- [Brandon] And there's
always something new popping up.
Snapchat, this, that.
- Great. There's
new ways they cover you.
You adjusted.
- [Brandon] It's overwhelming.
It can be overwhelming.
It's a lot going on.
- Listen, especially when the
other Brandon Marshall does shit
and you've got to deal with it.
- [Brandon] Mhmmm.
- I pay attention.
I understand life.
- [Brandon] Yeah, mhmmm.
- I'm just telling
you that, you know,
you're gonna regret
if we don't do this when
you had me to do it.
- [Brandon] Yes.
- When you're gonna leave
tens of millions of dollars
on the table.
- [Brandon] What
am I supposed to do?
- We need to figure
out a day to hang out.
- [Brandon] Mhmmm.
- I'll bring somebody, probably
Nate 'cause he's on my team and
he can scale all the projects.
We'll tell you
exactly what to do.
We'll hang out
for three, four hours.
We'll literally make
sure that everything's on
point on your phone.
We'll all talk together.
We'll create a
program that is feasible.
All we want to do is really talk
to you and understand what you
do and don't want to do.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- And then
reverse engineer that.
I'm not gonna make you do
shit you don't want to do.
But I'm gonna tell
you and explain to you
what you should do.
You're gonna pick from the
menu of those things and it will
change your game.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- It's where all
the economics are.
- [Brandon] Yeah, I know.
- Come with me Brandon,
I'll show you my office.
Come on, Mish.
What? You don't get to come
in the (mumbles) of a Bears fan.
- [Steph] Hi.
- [Gary] Hi.
Alright, give him a hug.
- [Brandon] What's up, man?
- Can I get a picture
with him real quick?
- [Gary] I don't know.
He's a grown man.
- He is a grown man and
I'm acting like a little kid.
Thanks, brother.
- Cool, man.
Alright, brother.
- Thank you, Gar.
- [Gary] It's the best.
Of course, Chris.
- [Steph] That's awesome.
Good to see you.
- [Gary] It was good to see you.
I'll be in in one sec.
I'll go in here actually.
You don't film this.
That's right so I want
you guys to do the following.
This is gonna fucking work.
Alright, iPhone, I want you to
record (censored) and fuckin'
(censored) for everything 'cause
they're improv but there's 50 of
them now here so I
don't give a fuck who it is,
get me two improv
kids in this office.
I want you to
literally film this.
I want you to literally film
them either in the office
or go film them at a bar
if you've got a second
on the phone 'cause
I want to show this to them.
It's going to be like, you know,
basically the skit it hey I'll
take a (censored) and the other
person is like what are you,
I want this
line, what is it 2009?
And I want the (censored) person
to punch the (censored) person
and then I want you to
impose the logos on their faces.
- So the one--
- Guys, I think
it's gonna be a home run.
I think, the
reason I'm so fired up,
this could be the
meeting that changes
the course of our agency.
I think they're
gonna make us do it.
I know if they do what I
want them to do it'll work.
I don't debate it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's 100.
It's just can we get
(censored) is an aggressive
Corporate America campaign.
It will work.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Alright, good work.
- Cool, thank you, Gary.
- [Gary] Yep. You
guys take the rest.
- [Group] Yep.
- [Gary] Okay, okay, and?
Yep. Okay.
- For 2110.
- Okay.
'Sup Jeff?
- [Jeff] 'Sup, buddy?
- How are you, man?
- [Jeff] Long time, no see.
- [Gary] It's good to see you.
- You too.
I didn't know you were here.
- Sure am.
- [Jeff] You got a coat?
- In the car.
Belarus blood, baby.
- [Jeff] Where you going?
- To do something with
Daymond John from Shark Tank.
- [Jeff] Cool.
- Oh, no just calling to say hi.
Things are good, how are you?
Anything interesting?
("The Plan" by Rey Topol)
That's a good strategy.
- [Sandra] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
What's your name?
- [Sandra] I'm an entrepreneur,
single mother.
- How are you?
What's your name?
- [Sandra] Sandra.
- [Gary] Sandra,
Gary, nice to meet you.
- [Sandra] Sorry my
hands are--
- No worries. Refreshing.
- [Sandra] Thank you,
you inspire me every day.
- [Gary] Want to come in?
- [Sandra] Oh, you would get it?
Thank you.
- [Gary] Where were you holding?
- [Sandra] You know how
many people you inspire daily?
- More than you think.
- I know. Amazing.
- No, thank you.
- [Sandra] And do you pat
yourself on the back for that?
- Yeah.
- [Sandra] Let me
do it, let me do it.
- I'm real.
I'm my number one fan.
On a serious note,
it's the best feeling.
- Yeah, you should be.
- Feels awesome.
- 'Cause I do it all by myself.
I have a five-year-old and I'm
running my own company and
I listen to you every morning.
- Thank you so much.
Means a lot to me.
- Yeah, it's inspiring.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for being
here. Yeah, it's awesome.
- [Man] Have you been
filled in on any of this?
- [Gary] This space?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah, but I like to
hear it from the horse's mouth.
- [Man] Well basically what
happened was we moved into this
building last January.
- The outdoor patio
right here we gonna have.
- [Gary] This is insane.
That's incredible.
- So typically you could see
the Empire State
Building right there.
- Oh God, I love New York.
I just love New York more
than every other city combined.
- [Man] Yeah, this is a cool
area too since it's the fashion
district and all these
people they're all working,
trying to make it happen.
- The thing with
New York is you never,
ever, ever go wrong.
- [Man] Oh yeah.
- My man!
- [Daymond] What's up, Gary?
- What are you trying to steal
all the outdoor
space in New York?
- [Daymond] I am, I am, I am.
Man, I appreciate you man.
I really,
I really appreciate it.
- No worries.
- [Daymond] So simple, had my
people call your people and that
shit just happened.
- That's the way it's done.
(group laughter)
That's how we do it.
- I know I owe you so,--
- It's alright man,
I'm thrilled to do it.
- I got you.
- How you doing?
- I'm doing great, man.
- This is incredible.
- It's great.
We're gonna have a
good time up in here.
- The outdoor
stuff is just incredible.
- Yeah. How's the family?
Everything good?
- [Gary] Everything's
really good, man.
How you been?
- [Daymond] You getting skinny.
- [Gary] Yeah, man.
I'm gonna look at it one day and
be like what the hell was
"More, more, more" 'cause
I was on it for three days.
Look who's here.
It's amazing.
- [Eytan] You doing alright?
- [Gary] It's great to see you.
Great.
- [Eytan] Thanks for coming.
You got the crew here.
- What are you doing here?
- Come to see you guys.
- I love it.
Clearly tell me where you want
me to roll in and I'll crush the
shit out of it for you.
I'm gonna micromanage the
whole thing to bring it the most
success, so I just
want to have a clear,
tomorrow I want to get out of it
whether it's a dollar or whether
it's, and you know me, I'm like
this is all family all of us.
I don't want you to worry for
even 30 seconds about what my
allocation is because
I want you to be successful.
It's way more important for me
of that than whether I get
200 or 500 or 74 million.
I'm about to take stage with
Daymond John for this fireside
chat but when
I get off, I'll call you.
Alright, bye-bye.
Had to humblebrag him.
(group laughter)
- [Daymond] Please welcome,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applause)
Thank you for
being here, of course.
("Malibu" by Rey Topol)
Everybody give
it up for GaryVee.
(audience applause)
Thank you, Gary for helping me
and for being here with us.
I appreciate it.
Let's get the
fuck up out of here.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Daymond] Good?
- Great.
- Thank you.
- I still want
to talk about fancy.
- Let's talk about fancy.
(audience laughter)
- Can we stay another minute?
Can we stay another minute?
- [Daymond] Yeah.
- I'm not
fulfilled yet. We're fancy.
We have to have this
conversation in this space.
Like every entrepreneur in
here has it so much better.
It's called the
internet at scale.
So many things are easier
than what we came up with.
Right, you can DM the
person and maybe get to them.
I want you guys to win
which is why I talk about this.
When the money dries up, when
the economy gets tighter all of
this goes away and the majority
of this market right now is on
bubble gum and dreams.
You've got to know
how to make money.
Like you have
to have a business.
Your product has to bring value.
Like the tried and true
is the only thing that's
gonna make you successful.
People running around
here trying to raise money.
Oh, I can't raise money because
I didn't go to
that kind of school.
Or I can't raise money because
I didn't come from
that kind of neighborhood.
Don't raise money, make money.
Doesn't take a hero to give
up a piece of their business.
Make it.
- So should you ever, so all
the balls to the wall concept,
should you quit
your day job or not?
- [Gary] I think you have
to be practical and hungry.
Like you should not quit
your day job if you got crazy
compounding interest
on your student loans or
you've got to pay your mortgage.
But what you shouldn't do is
have that job talk shit that
you're gonna build some big
business one day and then at
6 o'clock at night not work.
Like you need to
go to sleep at 3 A.M.
Like you need to back
your fucking mouth up.
Everybody's talking shit.
Everybody loves to hit me up.
GaryVee hustling.
I look at their
account and they're like
playing ping pong at 4:30.
(audience laughter)
Like people don't
understand what hustle is.
I took one
vacation in my twenties.
But I have crazy aspirations.
You should take 11 but don't
come telling me you're gonna buy
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
And so, the first thing is
figure out who you are and what
you want and then deploy real
self-awareness but I'm telling
you, the thing that I'm fearful
of and the reason I didn't step
off stage yet is it's been
so good for almost a decade.
This has been easy.
There's so much money out there.
Everybody's getting money for
their dumb ideas
that make no money.
And if you're not,
then you should really
even question that.
Like if you haven't
been able to raise money,
you really fucking suck.
(audience laughter)
Because the market is
ridiculously ridiculous.
Like terrible, like people are
getting funded for everything.
So if you haven't been able to
figure out how to get money,
you're a triple loser.
(audience laughter)
So the way to answer
that and punch me in
the face and tell me that you're
not is go make money instead of
dwelling why you
haven't raised it.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)
Two minutes, two minutes.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, let's go.
Ready?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Let's go.
Let's go, Ty.
- The thing that confused me was
when you said if you're looking
for money you're a loser.
- Yeah. You're gonna lose.
- But some people have to look
for money because they've taken
the concept this far--
- I get it.
- so they can't take it
any further without money--
- Let's break it down.
What I said was, in detail was
a lot of people's startups are
gonna fail here 'cause they're
starting the business just for
the money.
- For money, right.
- No, no, that's
actually not what I said.
'Cause I still
believe in that too.
I said the reason their business
is gonna fail is 'cause they're
building it to sell.
- Sell, right.
- That's different. Right?
That's what I actually said
and that's different because--
- There's no love in it.
There's no love in it.
- That's right,
they don't love it.
That's why everybody hits me up
and says should I go into the
marijuana business?
They're looking for trends.
Should I go into kale?
They're seeing trends and like
oh that's where the money is
gonna be and so they go there.
And the problem is if they're
not doing something you like you
can't work hard
enough to actually succeed.
It's too hard.
- You said a bunch of things.
You said, some of my
employees don't give a damn.
You can't expect the person,
but here's the problem.
One person I've seen
do that real good is Puff.
- Yep.
- So Puffy has found a way to
get his employees to bust their
ass but maybe
it's also the culture.
- Well, I don't know Puff well
enough to know but the real way
to do it and it's really worked
for me as well is I keep talking
to these guys and
figuring out what,
I spoke to Tyler.
I said something to this
kid when I saw he had talent,
I said, "Okay,
tell me the truth.
"Do you want to
work here for a year,
"leverage that you worked with
me and go do your own thing
"because I'll help you. We'll
have a nice one year courtship."
Right? This is how
they date now, right?
You know, we'll have a
great one year courtship and
I'll put you on more.
'Cause if you tell me
the truth then I know what
I'm dealing with. Right?
So I think the way to
get employees to really,
really crush for you
is do they want money?
Do they want work-life balance?
Do they want fame?
What do they want?
- What's their
version of success?
- What's their version of
success and where it really,
this is where you got to be real
good and this takes a lot of
leadership, you got to know
it's gonna change every day.
Because when they're 23 and
coming into New York City for
the first time and they
can work 18 hours a day.
- But what happen?
- What happens when
you fall in love and
you got to start a family?
You know like?
(laughs)
- But the thing is that
if you're trying to build a
company, the way that I'm
looking at it now based on me is
I don't need people who
are gonna sit at a desk,
I need playmakers.
So how do I find playmakers?
- You got to speak to them, you
got to find playmakers and then
tell them what you can
bring to them and ask them
what they want from you.
You got to make them feel
safe to tell you the truth.
- That's real.
- It's very real.
You got to get them to feel safe
to tell you the truth because
then you can play.
- [Man 2] You have been coming
up more and more recently--
- Gary, I'm
Alex's roommate, bro.
- [Gary] No way.
- What's up, man?
I work at TMZ.
- [Gary] How are you?
It's a real pleasure, man.
Real pleasure, stay well.
To me, what's
really interesting is
in CPG land is there's so many
variables besides the marketing.
That's the reason I've
been able to build my company.
It's just a macro game.
It's always a macro game.
- [Woman 2] It is and the other
thing is I think people go to
work to go to work
to make a difference.
- It's, you know, yeah.
I mean and it's also the
confines of that game, right?
Like you're an
unusual kind of character.
It's why I'm
allocating this time.
- [Woman 2] I really
appreciate that.
- It's because, it's not because
I'm doing anything other than
reacting to what you're doing.
I'm just counter-punching the
reality of the conversation.
I promise you
something about money.
Money is real funny.
Real funny.
Money doesn't care
what you look like.
You may think it does but
that's your fucking excuse.
Money wants to make money.
I'll give a Patriots fan
money that's how much
I want to make money.
(audience laughter)
You understand?
You can say anything you want
about you don't look the part,
white woman, black woman,
not from this country.
Money wants to make money
so if you're not getting it,
you suck.
So then go make it instead of
dwelling that the old white guy
in VC land's not
giving me any money.
It's 'cause your shit sucks and
so the only way you can prove me
wrong, is to go execute.
Another day of grinding ends.
Midnight, that's how we do it.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)